what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so I'll be honest with you guys
when dying wish first came out I have
never with the exception of one more day
in terms of like modern spider-man
history I've never even heard of a more
divisive stories and that's people there
were people out there who hated superior
spider-man they were just like no no
Peter Parker stage - and that's just
what it's always Peter Parker it needs
to be Peter Parker like they were
getting so bent out of shape but there
were other people like me who thought it
was amazing and it was just like this is
this is awesome so we're going to run
over this we will let you guys decide
now in terms of like how happy will
present like let people say this is the
actual pre lewd - superior spider-man I
consider it part of superior spider-man
I consider to be you know a part of the
main thing because I think it makes it
more cohesive I think it makes it more
like a cohesive BankPlus if you go and
buy superior spider-man you usually kind
of get you know dying dying which thrown
in but I really enjoyed this story
because what this does is it initially
just kind of picks up with with
spider-man Peter Parker right and there
were a few stories that took place in
between Spider Island and this but to me
those stories weren't particularly
interesting there were just moments in
those stories that were significant but
I found it very difficult to bring
myself to run over the entirety of like
ends of the earth just for like one
moment so it was it was kind of a weird
situation but of course you know this is
cool because it almost feels like a back
to back to basics for spider-man right
he's just going around he's doing a
spider-man thing he's saving people you
know he kind of realizes that he's got a
scar on his face from an attack that he
had when he was going against the Goblin
you know someone so poor but he's kind
of going through his messages this is
where things get a little weird because
something seems a bit off right like
he's getting few messages you know he
gets messages from Mary Jane watch today
where Mary Jane's like hey look at you
come into the club tonight he gets
messages from from max Modell saying hey
you're your review that's coming up you
know for for horizon lives and you know
he's got par that he has to spend with
but Aunt May and it's so on and so forth
so his life is really packed to the brim
and of course is kind of cool because
he's going through he's you know
remaking his uh his spider wedding fluid
it's so on and so forth the things start
to get a little funny when he encounters
Mary Jane at her club and what he does
is he really kind of approaches her and
he says like hey look we've been dancing
around this long enough it's time that
we get back together now this was crazy
because it was it was
damn flawed kind of toying with the idea
that Mary Jane Watson defeat of Harker
we're going to get back together again
and in fact this is like one of the
things that that like a like the
die-hard fans wanted so much more they
really really really wanted Mary Jane
Watson and they wanted Peter Parker to
get back together and they really wanted
them to be reunited but in a lot of ways
it was just kind of like Marvel he
basically said that's never going to
happen so the idea was well maybe Dan
smart will lounge ahead maybe dad's not
will be the reason why it does happen of
course it doesn't really seem to be the
case it's sad you know it's just kind of
like hey look we got to go hang out with
you grow up man
yada yada yada but of course you know
spending time with Aunt May it's also
interrupted by the fact that he's
getting a request to basically see
Doctor Octopus Doctor Octopus it's
calling him by name Peter Parker and so
of course he ends up meeting with the
New Avengers you know Captain America
and war and so on and then shows up
there now this is where things get crazy
because when I was going through this it
was just like wow I never owned were
originally reading this it was like what
in the world is going on but it also
seemed like Dan's font was paying an
appropriate tribute right I mean Doctor
Octopus was basically died that's when
the gist of his character really ever
since the events of spider-man Big Time
he's just been in the background and
he's been dying he's been orchestrating
plans here and there for the plans
really seem to be just his attempt to
cut a deal to implement one final
successful campaign before he passed on
and this moment seemed to be kind of
damn fraud sitting down and saying okay
look Doctor Octopus was died he's really
spider-man's most formidable foe with
the exception of maybe Zinna more
carnage but in terms of long-standing
villains
you know he's won us probably has oldest
and most dangerous foes it's really just
the right thing to do
it's really just the right thing to do a
symbol you notice I have Doctor Octopus
and spider-man do a send-off to one
another but what ends up happening is we
find out that this is not Doctor Octopus
this is Peter Parker their minds have
been swapped and Peter Parker really
spider-man's just like yeah I have all
your memories all your experiences
everything that makes you who you are is
now me I look like you everyone believes
you're me you are Doctor Octopus let me
tell you something of course when this
reveal came out it was like why like
holy cow it was mind-blowing because he
liked Doctor Octopus are sorry because
he only got a few hours left you know
and he starts to be basically it'll
begin the process of dying to keep them
alive as best they can the Peter Parker
he does fine I just kind of leave and
he's like well that's that and he just
basically just kind of takes off and so
one of what we do is it
we pick up with the second half of dying
wish and really I guess the first half
is kind of a prelude but we basically
pick up with you know dying wish proper
and what dying wish does is it answers
the question how in the world did this
happen kind of Doctor Octopus managed to
swamp mines with Peter Parker because
remember this just came out of left
field it was just suddenly Peter
Parker's mind is in the body of Doctor
Octopus in the mind of Doctor Octopus is
in the body of Peter Parker and so it
was like what in the heck happened that
went do all this well of course
initially it picks up with Peter Parker
worrying about what things may happen
what Doctor Octopus might do what's
ironic about this is the doctor
octopus's to do any of those things it's
like I would say the Doctor Octopus is
spider-man it's probably better than
Peter Parker I like Doctor Octopus in
spite of that better than I like Peter
Parker is spider-man it was interesting
had it gone on long enough the novelty
would have worn off but for what a
superior spider-man was I think he was
better than Peter Parker but of course
his maked serve is that Doctor Octopus
is basically going to swindle his
friends and family you know that he's
going to force himself on the Mary Jane
Watson stage we're going to steal the
fortune or steal the money of Jay jonah
Jameson senior and Aunt May he's going
to kill a lot of his superhero friends
because he has access to the Avengers
mansion and they don't know that they
don't know that this is Doctor Octopus
he goes through and starts experiencing
the memories of Doctor Octopus doc Ock's
abusive father the first time the Doctor
Octopus became Doctor Octopus the time
that Doc Ock and they got together
physically physically together but did
he also begin that's what are we going
to go into the whole idea how it is the
Doctor Octopus is able to pull off the
mind swap and what ended up happening is
of course Doctor Octopus had a helmet of
sorts that was used to basically control
these little nanobots that he had that
went all the way back to spider-man big
time and of course Peter Parker has
taken this this device to control these
nanobot so you know basically brain
doctor octopus's various campaigns to an
end but he had also taken the technology
of the device and incorporated in his
own spider armor outfit and what this
did is it gave Doctor Octopus
a direct line into the mind of Peter
Parker he literally opened the door for
Doc Ock and that's what's so cool about
this story it shows how smart Doctor
Octopus is he was planning ahead all
these campaigns that he had was he
realized he was I was with a sole
purpose of basically finding a way to
enter to map Peter Parker's mind and
that's exactly what he did he just
started going through and Matty
Peter Parker's Martin and when the
opportunity came he basically swapped
their bodies and nobody knew what was
going on it took place he lost him
nobody had any idea that that happened
and so the whole point though the whole
concept here is that Peter Parker is now
panicking because he has to find a way
to get back into his normal body well of
course this also coincides with Curt
Connors so the cool thing about this is
their plots kind of pulling out all the
stops he's really just kind of yanking
all these things out for example he says
that where previously the lizard was
believed to have just been this mindless
beast you know this it's hooked to doc
Connors worse panic set in truth doc
Connors mind is alive and well in the
body of the lizard the lizard is a
scientifically intelligent as doc
Connors was you know it's not a mindless
speech is an intelligent being inside an
incredible body doc Connors just can't
go back to the way he was before but
this is cool because this is basically
you know Connors spilling the beans on
who he is and what he's about and it
changes everything for Peter Parker
because in his mind he's like you should
go tell someone dr. Cotterill doc
Connors is not the bad guy the lizard is
the bad guy tell someone what's going on
but of course then the question has to
be asked like who's going to believe him
like who would believe it if you told
them that you know always really me doc
Connors inside the body of those if
who's going to believe him that it you
know who's gonna believe I mean I guess
maybe psychics could figure that out but
in truth it just creates a situation the
doc Connors really can't seem to get out
of this look what is up happening is
Peter Parker begins to sort of put two
and two together throwing to the
memories of dr. octopus of Otto Octavius
going through his mind reading his
memories you know learning what he's
about he begins to realize that Doc Ock
always had a contingency plan for every
situation if he were ever captured
whatever the case may be he always had a
contingency plan in this instance he had
a contingency plan to reform the
sinister six and break himself out of
the raft I remember the raft of the
prison that exists really you know out
in the middle of nowhere it's mill man's
land people who were taken there or
isolated from virtually everyone there
this design explicitly for the purpose
of keeping villains in isolation but
when he does is he basically initiates a
protocol that was owned by dr. octopus
that sets in motion the reactivation of
the sinister six this is when we get
hydro-man this is when we get the other
scorpion when we get all these different
guys coming together for the purpose of
getting dr. octopus added it of course
again in their mind they don't know
which Peter Parker they believe that is
dr. octopus and that's why this works so
well because it's the street crosses
both hot you know with this scenario
it's where you know Doctor Octopus can
parade around and the MA
in the body of Peter Parker and people
believe that Doctor Octopus is Peter
Parker Peter Parker can parade around in
the body of Doctor Octopus such as it is
and lead people to believe that he's
actually Doctor Octopus and that's
exactly what happened with the sinister
six really it's a sinister five more
like you know showing up here and they
basically it's basically Peter Parker
saying look you guys got to get me out
of here you guys got to get me out of
here you know we have to go and we have
to find spider-man we're going to go and
we're going to find and we're going to
defeat spider-man so again it's using
the perception of who these characters
aren't and in order for them to benefit
themselves now of course again this one
should continue on and in issue number
700 which is the official start of
superior spider the problem with this is
that issue number 700 is 100 pages long
so really it's not practical to try to
roll that into this video otherwise you
would end up with a video that's about
an hour long and I'm not going to make
it hour long video but if you guys are
new here the comments explained make
sure you guys to the sub button to
become part of the report if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you guys on
it please
[Music]
you